certains jours les dieux du ciel sont en
colère tous les jours ceux de la terre
risque de s'énerver mais tous les jours
une trentaine d'hommes remonte les
pentes du kawah ijen le plus grands
volcans d'indonésie
le plus redoutable aussi le kawah ijen
le cratère vert
tu as
la gueule du dragon crash sans arrêt ses
vapeurs de soufre jaune l'odeur d'oeuf
pourri brûle les poumons
pour
[Musique]
dans les paniers entre 70 et 100 kg de
soufre solidifier
[Musique]
2300 mètres d'altitude la sortie du
cratère le crissement du balancier de
bambou va rythmer toute la descente vers
la vallée depuis 20 ans andy est un des
porteurs de soufre du kawah ijen à derna
du golfe et charlie noms comme sebastian
ne fait pas attention à l'équilibré
ça fait mal au dos il faut trouver
l'équilibré entre le panier le bras et
prendre la cadence sinon on peut tomber
et se faire mal au dos je ne peux pas me
permettre d'avoir mal au dos le médecin
et les médicaments coûtent trop cher
c'est pour ça qu'il faut bien maîtriser
la technique si tu n'as pas cette
technique ça peut être fatal pour ces
hommes de ben niang à l'est de java le
soufre du volcan c'est le travail toute
l'année
[Applaudissements]
après deux heures de marche les porter
en droit à une pause pour une première
pesée
un premier contrôle combien ça pèse 80
kg aujourd'hui je suis content parce que
je suis en forme
dans mes amis aussi
c'est une bonne journée pour nous tous
le terrain a dit combien ça pèse 65 kg
et vous combien vous peser 1 57 kg
marzouki et sa tête de pirates
l'un des plus costauds de tous les
porteurs 85 kg on est à la moitié du
chemin
on va se reposer un peu avant de
descendre jusqu'en bas
c'est dans cette cabane candy et ses
compagnons vivent la moitié de l'année
quinze jours chaque mois loin de chez
eux
ici ils partagent tous sous le doublé
c'est du lait du soja c'est bon pour
nettoyer les vapeurs de soufre
ça donne des forces aussi pour continuer
à porter le souffre comme la de katia
avec des glaçons c'est comme un dessert
année sauf qu'à l'étape il n'y a pas de
jolie vendeuse pas de femmes ici on est
entre hommes il s'accorde une heure de
pause le temps de récupérer
mes pieds sont blessés ça fait mal
pourtant ce qui suit là c'est ce qui
protège le mieux on peut le garder une
semaine si je mettais des chaussettes du
marché je ne ferais même pas une journée
avec marzouki le pirate est le
responsable de la cuisine
il n'y a pas de femmes ici c'est nous
qui faisons la cuisine
aujourd'hui on prépare des légumes du
riz du café du poisson salé et du soja
oui du poisson salé marzouki c'est le
meilleur cuisinier de toute l'équipe
quand il était jeune il a appris à faire
la cuisine
avec lui c'est bon je travaille ici
depuis 20 ans j'avais 15 ans quand j'ai
commencé au début je ne portais pas
j'aurai paraît le chemin d'ici jusqu'en
bas ensuite j'ai commencé à porter
d'abord 30 ou 40 kilos je n'ai pas porté
75 kg tout de suite
le travail ici est difficile parfois
j'ai le cafard
parce que je suis loin de ma famille
quand on est ensemble et qu'on discute
ça va j'oublie que je suis loin de ma
femme et de ma fille mais le soir par
exemple quand je vais dormir je pense à
elle
heureusement je sais qu'avec mon salaire
elle ne manque de rien ça me réconforte
mais c'est pas facile c'est le travail
c'est comme ça en fait ils ne doivent
pas traîner à 4 heures le camion de la
fabrique sera en bas ils doivent être au
rendez vous
dans leur tête une seule préoccupation
le rythme
mon bras sert de balancier pour trouver
le bon équilibre
si tu gardes le bras ballon le long du
corps ça ne marche pas il y en a qui
préfèrent quand ça monte
d'autres quand ça descend moi je trouve
ça plus facile quand ça monte d'eau
au pied du volcan deuxième contrôle ce
sont les employés de la fabrique qui
vérifie maintenant les pois bien entendu
on est payé au kilo porté ici au volcan
on n'a pas de monnaie alors ils donnent
des cigarettes à la place une cigarette
ça fait 150 roupies donc pour 300
roupies
ça fait deux cigarettes c'est comme ça
pour 50 roupies il donne un bon de toute
façon nous on prend tout pour 80 kg
aujourd'hui j'ai gagné 12 francs ça
permet à ma famille de vivre pendant
deux jours
si je travaillais en bas au village dans
une rizière ou une plantation de café je
gagnerai la moitié et je n'aurai pas la
sécurité de l'emploi
quelques mètres encore jusqu'au camion
de la fabrique en quinze jours
cette équipe sur huit tonnes de soufre
de la gueule du dragon
[Musique]
andy ses compagnons une heure avant la
nuit pour remonter jusqu'à leurs cabanes
à mi hauteur sur la pente du volcan 100
km sont charge
[Musique]
les réveils sont toujours un peu
difficiles les muscles douloureux
la remise en marche de la machine se
fait lentement
celui là il peut porter 70 kg pas plus
parce que le bambou est mince des pays
comme une atp
celui là c'est presque pareil mais plus
épais on peut mettre jusqu'à 85 kg il
n'est que compagnie celui là il a un
double bon bout tu peux porter plus de
100 kg avec
6 heures du matin pour être au
rendez-vous de 16 heures avec le camion
ils n'ont plus de temps à perdre
pas un regard pour le spectacle pas un
regard pour la gueule du dragon première
tâche s'attaquer au soufre qui s'est
solidifiée au cours de la nuit
en fait le soufre et liquides lorsqu'il
sort des fissures du cratère il est à
400 degrés
les hommes ont installé des tuyaux pour
le diriger vers cet endroit un peu plus
plat où il se refroidit et se transforme
en pierre
ça c'est le soufre liquide
il sort un peu plus aux 15 mètres au
dessus il descend dans les tuyaux il est
bouillant à l'air il refroidit et
devient solide souvent un tuyau casse il
faut le remplacer
pas simple avec le liquide qui n'arrête
pas de couler brûlant on remplace les
tuyaux régulièrement pour produire plus
de souffle il ya des fuites les repères
du soufre alors il faut réparer tous les
tuyaux
ce puits ont fait quinze mètres de long
c'est un assemblage de 25 morceaux
plus on monte plus l'air devient
irrespirable
[Musique]
même les plus endurcis ne résiste pas à
la sfic si on a la technique pour
travailler dans le soufre si on ne
l'avait pas ce serait vraiment dur
il faut savoir respirer au bon moment
quand il ya une éclaircie
il faut en profiter dans la vapeur il
faut arrêter de respirer
on a beau connaître la technique
personne n'est capable de résister au
souffle du dragon et à s'attaquer à ça
fait mal il ya trop de vapeur quand y en
aura moins ça ira mieux j'ai du mal à
respirer mais ça va il faut que je me
repose un peu tous les jours c'est comme
ça oui oui c'est dur c'est dur les yeux
ça va mais c'est les poumons qui brûlent
les vapeurs de soufre sont entré dedans
ça ne rend pas malade mais ça fait
tousser l'opération tuyaux leur a fait
perdre trois heures parfois le dragon se
met en colère
would you know se souvient d'un matin de
juin 1978
d'abord il a beaucoup plu il était 11
heures du matin il y avait des éclairs
ce jour là il y avait beaucoup de monde
dans le cratère une soixantaine de
porter on avait eu là bas ici partout il
y en avait même au bord du lac
de la fumée noire est sorti du cratère
et tout à coup un homme s'est évanoui
quelqu'un est venu l'aider
il s'est évanoui et aussi aux hommes
sont tombés comme ça quatre d'entre eux
sont morts de était des copains très
proche j'étais vraiment triste
en août 1993 il ya encore eu un accident
j'étais là avec marzouki l'attaquant ne
s'attendait à rien accord et d'un coup
il ya eu une explosion au milieu du lac
a explosé très fort boum
on a eu très peur on a tous couru pour
sortir du cratère c'était vraiment très
impressionnant on n'a pas dormi de la
nuit
on pensait que le volcan allait exploser
et nous tuer tous le lendemain on est
redescendu quand même c'était incroyable
les tuyaux avait disparu il n'y avait
plus de soufre non plus de l'ine l'eau
du lac était monté de 20 mètres il y
avait de l'eau jusque là bas les tuyaux
et le point avait disparu le gravier
aussi il n'y avait plus rien le lac
avait tout emporté
les morceaux de tuyaux de 50 kg ont tous
été balayé par l'eau du lac
depuis 1985 le gouvernement indonésien a
mis en place un système de surveillance
de l'activité du volcan 24 heures sur 24
un fonctionnaire surveille ce
sismographe son rôle donné l' alerte
c'est une responsabilité importante
surveillez le sismographe pour la
sécurité des gens qui travaillent dans
le volcan
si nous le testons à risque nous
prévenons les porteurs par radio
si on n'était pas là pour surveiller il
pourrait y avoir les catastrophes ça
pourrait être fatal mais ce
fonctionnaire n'a pas vu venir la
dernière éruption alors les porteurs
préfère s'en remettre à des forces dont
la compétence est plus mystérieuse que
ce matin ni margeta pas d'être calme au
discours qu'a tour à tour animera kwassa
yamagata la matanie nikita talent
platane c'est la torah fia
là
[Musique]
et là bas
ici on est musulman mais l'aide du
prophète n'est pas suffisante
je crois aussi aux esprits qui habite le
cratère aux fantômes du volcan je suis
sûr qu'ils existent
tous les matins les mêmes gestes tous
les matins il faut tailler les plaques
chacun des couples et sienne en pensant
à l'épreuve qui l'attend le chemin le
plus important c'est de bien équilibrer
les deux paniers à gauche et à droite
sinon on peut se faire déséquilibré dans
la montée aujourd'hui j'ai pris à peu
près 100 kg 100 kg hier j'avais emporté
113 kg
rambo confirme sa réputation c'est lui
le plus costaud il ne faut surtout pas
faire comme ça d'accord il faut passer
dessous avec les deux épaules après le
lever se mettre en route
10h du matin il leur reste six heures
pour être au rendez vous du camion six
heures au cours desquelles ils doivent
rester concentrés
la moindre seconde d'inattention est
interdite aux débats qui est adapté à
chaque fois il faut bien regarder où on
met le pied il ya il faut choisir la
bonne pierre cd si on pose le pied sur
une pierre qui roule on tombe et on peut
se faire très mal
le ravin et profond
emma
amiri
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
droite ou par aastra thiam ont eu à
carennac la ja
pendant ces six heures trois pauses
c'est l'ami cratère dans la montée celle
du déjeuner à la cabane et une dernière
dans la descente vers 15 heures
j'ai pas mal aux jambes mais j'ai un peu
mal aux épaules c'est pas grave ça me
gêne un peu pour porter me fait pas trop
mal c'est quand je change mon panier des
poules
j'ai une mauvaise technique
les autres sont meilleurs que moi c'est
pour ça que je suis écorché je suis pas
très doué pour changer des poules
[Musique]
leurs quinze jours de travail sont
finies les porteurs vont être remplacés
par une autre équipe
il rentre au village pour quinze jours
de repos
il
par endroits le chemin nécessite
quelques précautions
descendent trop fort le camion risque de
se renverser
si le soufre tombe c'est pas grave nous
c'est plus grave
mentalement ça
dans la vallée les rizières autour du
premier village celui où se trouve la
fabrique le terminus du camion
[Applaudissements]
la date d'examen
c'est ici que le soufre est préparé pour
la vente
nettoyez et emballés dans des sacs de 50
kg le soufre du kawah ijen est pure à
99,9 pour cent
un des meilleurs du monde il servira à
fabriquer de l'engrais des pneus du
papier des allumettes ou à blanchir le
sucre de canne
trente kilomètres plus loin trois heures
de bus andy arrive chez lui à mouchard
une ville résidentielle
sa maison est la plus belle du quartier
elle représente tout pour lui c'est sa
fierté
il est le seul porteur du kawah ijen à
vivre dans du dur
ça rigole pas
e
on se prennent didot cap à gaza il ya la
guinée un accord
je suis vraiment très content je ne peux
pas dire à quel point je suis heureux de
retrouver ma fille et ma femme j'ai
vraiment peur quand il est sur le volcan
notre fille est encore petit il faut
payer l'école et je prie tous les jours
pour qu'il n'arrive rien dans mon mari
les abbés est né à ce média je suis
vraiment très content parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé pour faire construire
cette maison j'ai commencé à économiser
quand j'étais encore célibataire cette
maison représente 20 ans de travail et
tout ça à certaines périodes je me suis
privé de nourriture pour la faire
construire pour acheter ce frigo j'ai
économisé pendant sept mois j'en avais
pas besoin mais c'est yuki ma fille qui
me l'a demandé je pouvais lui offrir
parce que je suis encore en forme pour
travailler je suis content de les faire
plaisir là c'est le salon c'est ma fille
qui l'a choisi mais ce bureau si elle a
vu le même chez une amie
je lui ai acheté pour faire ses devoirs
là c'est sa chambre je lui ai acheté 3
uniforme c'est nécessaire pour l'école
pour moi l'éducation c'est très
important je lui ai acheté de bonnes
chaussures aussi et pour l'encourager a
bien travaillé je lui ai offert ses deux
peluches
[Musique]
ça se corse car les motards listeria
j'aime bien les cuisines de ma femme
c'est meilleur que sur le volcan quand
je suis là bas je perds cinq kilos ici
je pèse 70 kg là au bout de deux jours
je fais 65 kg à chaque fois je perds
cinq kilos les marques hino
[Musique]
marzouki le pirate lui aussi rentrer à
la maison il habite un village de
paysans dans une maison traditionnelle
[Musique]
les murs sont en bambou le sol en terre
battue son salaire de porter marzouki ne
l'a pas mis dans sa maison il a fait un
autre placement des vaches qui l'élève
derrière chez lui c'est sa tirelire
regardez elle a grandi elle a fait ses
cornes ses vaches représente cinq ans de
travail
je les ai acheté 400 mille roupies
aujourd'hui elle va le 2 millions de
roupies chacune
je ne suis pas très riche mais pour moi
c'est une épargne s'il m'arrive un
accident sur le volcan je pourrais
vendre une vache pas que des messiria la
fabrique m'a proposé de devenir
superviseur j'ai refusé deux fois déjà
je gagne plus d'argent pourtant le
soufre comme ça je peux continuer à
guetter ma fille est le plus important
pour moi c'était je veux lui offrir des
études pour qu'elle est un métier mieux
que le mien je veux qu'elles aillent à
l'école primaire au collège et à
l'université un filles c'est toute ma
vie et à la tête a dit
[Musique]
pendant sa quinzaine de repos andy
consacre plusieurs journées à sa grand
mère c'est lui qui lui donne de l'argent
pour vivre la cnil elle mange de la noix
de bétel c'est un petit excitant
les hommes fument les femmes mangent de
la noix de bétel le tabasser pour se
nettoyer les dents
ma mère et mon père m'ont élevé ici dans
cette maison
ma mère est morte quand j'étais petit
mon père s'est remarié il est parti
vivre ailleurs je suis resté avec ma
grand mère c'est elle qui a fini de
m'élever
andy profite également de ces jours de
repos pour s'occuper de la rizière de sa
grand-mère 20 mètres de large sur 30
mètres de long deux récoltes par an une
bonne économie
j'aime bien travailler au cratère parce
que je gagne bien ma vie ici je produis
du riz pour toute ma famille ça m'évite
d'en acheter
je n'achète jamais de riz si je devais
en acheter je mettrais moins d'argent de
côté
c'est pour ça que je travaille ici
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce matin-là marzouki le pirate se lève
tôt la journée particulière plusieurs
fois par an il est l'un des maîtres de
cérémonie de coude à loum bing coude à
l'ompi
c'est la fête de l'homme cheval tout le
village est rassemblé dans la cour de la
fabrique
marzouki revêt son costume sous l'oeil
dandy tous les porteurs de l'équipe sont
là les visages sont graves
c'est la survie de tous ceux qui
descendent dans la gueule du dragon qui
va se jouer
on attire les mauvais génies qui sont
dans le cratère on les fait venir ici
il rentre dans l'esprit des hommes
maquiller le mauvais génie celui
m
il est en transe pour apaiser sa colère
les villageois lui donne à manger du riz
et d'autres mais moins courant
[Musique]
non
tha
je
[Musique]
quand le génie est en transe il peut
manger du verre du feu du riz n'importe
quoi quelquefois ils mangent des poulets
vivants quand il est en transe comme ça
il faut éloigner les poulets à moi je
suis chargé de le surveiller
sinon ils pourraient s'échapper est même
allé dans les rizières pour manger le
riz sur pied
[Musique]
son festin est finie le mauvais génie du
volcan il refuse vaincu les porteurs de
soufre pour retourner dans la gueule du
dragon
[Musique]
homo
mon bon tour
bongo
oh
[Musique]
depuis 1993 coda looping la fête de
l'homme cheval a réussi à calmer le
kawah ijen
il n'y a pas eu d'explosion
[Musique]